I discovered that a light microscope can
see sharper pictures that what people
believed in the 20th century more than
hundred years and this is important
because light microscopy is the only way
by which you can look into transparent
things important things such as cells
living cells or tissue and the presence
light microscope that I invented allows
you to see details that you couldn't see
before but the basic discovery was that
in the 20th century so before I made my
work people believed that you have two
separate things if you look into the
microscope if you want to see them
separately these on the see the details
by focusing the light very sharply but I
discovered is that you can overcome this
barrier by making the molecules that we
look at distinct difference if the
molecules are different you can see
things separately and you can tell them
apart and that that was the discovery
that has led now to microscopes that are
not limited by the focusing of light
anymore but you can see things at much
greater detail because the separation of
things is done by the molecules